- Hello internet. How you doing?
You all right?
- Hi internet.
- Yeah.
- So I saw a crazy Japanese video,
where people were putting,
oh that was a good shot,
putting rubber bands around a watermelon.
And I'm quite thirsty
for watermelon right now,
so we're gonna cut one
open, using the classic
Japanese method, by the sounds of it.
Here we go, start doing it.
- Yeah?
- Yeah.
Just pile them on.
- This might take a while.
- This could take some time.
- Check it out at the top as well.
And the sides, oh it's starting
to cracking everywhere.
It's perspiring.
- Bloody hell.
It went.
It severed it in half.
Oh my God!
Wow!
- [Daniel] Oh my God.
- That's incredible.
- [Gavin] The ball of rubber
bands just went over there.
- [Daniel] I wanna find that, where is it?
- [Gavin] It's over there, look!
All of these elastic bands
were wrapped around it
and it just sort of,
it started leaking water,
like dripping everywhere
and then it just gave up,
- [Gavin] Yeah.
- Just
- [Gavin] We were just
about to put more on,
and then it just,
like all the rubber bands
just turned into a rubber
band ball and shot out.
Leaving the melon-
- [Daniel] All I saw with
my own eyes was this,
Yeah?
- [Gavin] Yeah.
And that was just preserved perfectly.
- [Gavin] It's like how to
cut a melon perfectly in half.
- [Daniel] Look at that.
- [Gavin] Look at it.
Do you reckon if you did
that to a human head,
it would eventually, like, cave in?
- Eventually.
Yeah.
Oh it's starting to fizz a little bit.
Oh it went!
- Hit me in the head!
- It fully hit me in the head.
Want a bit?
- [Gavin] Yeah.
Thanks, mate.
- Good noise, though.
Good noise.
Good scoffing sound.
Listen, listen.
- [Gavin] Do that again.